bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo momento sono chirito e oggi
entrambi sword art on line
credo aspetto mesi o per cavo oggi raga
giochiamo l'account io che vanno bene
magari se ti va di joystiq seleziona il
tuo controller amico mio io ho quello
giusto vavalà pre vicolo avvertenza
questo gioco non ho letto la vertenza
quindi moriremo welcome to the man who
knew game ho capito ma è e basso non ci
arrivo sad e prego che è venuta da
counting grazie prego preparati hanno un
viaggio spirituale come non è mai visti
prima va bene
sono curioso amico mio fammi vivere la
voce un cubo di rubik
se abbastanza in gamba gara al camping
amico mio faccio video da 1600 anni
no è però so niente adesso in italia non
è facile ecco tre mesi ricchi e morti
grazie tragiche morti
scegli il tuo preferito tenendo il tasto
tipo e prende gli oggetti tanto tutti
avranno scelto questo sicuro scelte io
dovrei league
un classico di rick morsi sono convinto
di questo esame le faccio ma perché ci
siano i ceri che morti cosa c'entra il
gioco fammi capire cosa che devo fare
motivation cos'è sta roba
però andò dove il telefono pronti
tu devi essere il nostro nuovo contabili
o contabile come faccio io non so fare
il contabile non so contare oscar h ma
cosa sta succedendo ma via giusti e la
realtà virtuale nella realtà virtuale
mav e
uars action sono orgoglioso delle mie di
che cosa vado a giocare ogni volta
grandissimo vorrei capire il senso mio
dio
la temperatura è ok 22 gradi mazza mi
spiegate cosa devo fare in questo gioco
tranne sentire gente che parla in tutto
questo mentre la casetta buongiorno
ma io per niente adesso sono dentro un
gioco dentro un gioco che è successo
questo wire nel guar polizia vaga non è
più breve di friendly in casa sto
giocando l'uso nella ragano sta capendo
se adesso iscritto vasta lysacek batteri
in casa rai di saurik ha devo mettere la
batteria alla mente olina metto lì
questo continua a insultarmi nel mentre
io sto prendendo la sua roba mezzo vai e
cosa sta succedendo quello mi insultava
fortissimo celano di un later nei ter
nell'albero ma mi fai capire ma
veramente un gioco non family friendly
wahr no ma scusate non capisco il gioco
è veramente così
mi dispiace ragazzi mi dispiace sia
acceso si è acceso ma cosa sta dicendo
beh ti la verità io gli sto prendendo
per tiago sta succedendo devo entrare la
loro gang facendo cagate c'è un libro di
nubì che però una pesca ma chi crosta
cercando il ragazzo scherzo non è
abbastanza
e allora guarda questo sto rompendo quel
mattone una lattina si è caduta per ora
per entrare nella gang ha dovuto fare il
suo casinò a un visore guarda il tutto
va bene lo prendo io sto cercando di
brega che gioco incredibile cioè io e
fanno tutto loro non devo io non dico
niente
fanno tutto loro questo forse era meglio
non farlo vedere anche ora che saremo
per sempre però non sei megan fox minino
a ti serve ti serve il coltello raga
occhio occhio questo è il più bel gioco
archi abbia mai visto bene sono più
tranquillo adesso c'è una pillola ma
come mi sono affacciato la pillola va
teletrasportato va bene a raga abbiamo
la pillola blu la pillola rossa io vado
nella tana del bianconiglio ok
sto sempre diventando una roba un
inception di inception quindi non so
bene cosa sta succedendo a posso
suonarvi va bene arrivo non so con cosa
suonarvi beh per l'inizio
fate voi non posso fare questa cosa e la
farete voi grazie
fammi vedere una squadra ti prego
qualsiasi cosa ci sia acido do not to
drink ho vomitato l'acido penso di
essere morto in un gioco dove non si può
morire però fa niente stavo suonando ed
era la cosa un po ambigua perché quei
due stavano un po anzi manda a siamo
usciti cos'è sto morendo chi ha ucciso
quello ma quelli dovrebbero essere la
quelli contro quello incazzatissimi ma
questo è mio avvocato difensore e
scusate non sono stato io
si sta difendendo alla corte suprema
della realtà virtuale ospita smart sanno
applicazioni sta difendendo ancora scusa
file ai cittadini
no ai ho un sacco di avvocati capito e
li possa uccidere tutti ma chi è sto con
benissimo questo si sta cagando sotto
tono
[Musica]
sto iniziando a parlare è scusa mi
escono dall'altro da soli è morto
non sono stato io comunque uccidere lui
sto facendo fuori solo questi no dove
michael a papa dentro michael
senta ma io non posso fare questa vita
qua mi scusi ma mi sono un po cagato
addosso si sa questa è la gang di prima
e uno sta morendo
vi do una mano vi do una mano io
scherzavo aspetto va bene non fa niente
non rischia di metterlo giù sorgeva aia
ha la mia zheng oddio che succede rai
che è difficilissimo farli fuori
difficilissimo sì sto provando ragazzi
mi disse ragazzi sapete cosa mi sembra
se ciò che mi sembra turchi flight of
law wing in più ha praticamente quello
mi sembrò ragazzi stiamo morendo e morta
anche lui
ecco ecco ci penso io a posto sparare mi
fermato è bellissimo
faccio io
ah no è una pistola spara semi del i
fotoni carmela prima a quest'ora saremmo
tutti i vigili maledizione porca vacca
mi sta simpatica l'asiago dietro dai
ragazzi mi sento come i want it è
bellissimo sparo ai segni però è già
qualcosa
sono morti tutti però fa niente ma c'era
anche lui ma cavolo sono stufi di
mannaia la morte comunque veramente
bello sto gioco se non forse che io
faccio esattamente le cose che non
dovrei fare però è bellissimo c'è trova
soddisfazione tolgo posso non promette
non prometto niente bene sta roba
no mi dispiace
va bene facciamo saltare in aria non far
arrivare il posto alla miccia ma scusami
sa esattamente quello che volevo fare io
raga vabbè fa niente button è successo
tutto così in fretta mi dispiace siamo
morti tutti però è stata affidata fosse
uccidermi ancora non è ancora finita
devo raggiungere la pistola che il jong
lo strano ragazza è un fake credit no
era giusto
e stato molto bello va bene è stato
molto carino se non ci sono anche un
sacco di cose da poter giocare già
presente posso scegliere le cose da
rigiocare di prima
il discorso è che ci sono e un gioco un
po pv credo quindi possiamo fare altre
cose
bellissimo mi è piaciuto un sacco era
molto narrativo quindi dovevi leggere
bene tutto e io non sono stato io l'ho
letto ma ho tagliato tutte le parti che
sono cioè non è da tanto da youtube come
e più da viverlo pro bello cioè nel
senso mi è piaciuto da giocare uno dei
migliori da youtube normale però bello
comunque però vi sia piaciuto questo
account in gi adesso vado a farmi
insultare da qualcun altro se noi
lavoristi iscrivetevi schiacciato anche
la campanella per essere aggiornati sui
nuovi video che escono e io cercherò di
non importunare esseri negli alberi bene
ragazzi
[Musica]